blindspot ik tells the story of two
friends Colin and miles Colin is on his
last few days of probation both of them
work for a moving company in which they
pack up people's belongings take their
stuff to the dump and he's trying to
survive these last few days on probation
where he has a curfew at 11 p.m. with
his incredibly volatile friend Myles and
this guy is really hard to handle but
they've been friends forever and so he
feels a need to continue to be with this
guy or at least help him in some way but
he's also trying to restart his life and
not go down the path he was already
going down this movie was incredible I
thought it was really amazing I had
really no anticipation going in I hadn't
even seen a trailer but I had heard from
various people that it was really good I
didn't even know it was about I mean
what I just told you is kind of
scratches the surface of what this is
about it's really a film about a lot of
things most of it is about stuff that's
happening in Oakland California and the
way it affects these two guys and how
life can be really hard for both of them
in different ways and I loved how the
film explored some really difficult
subject matter and some really intense
stuff and it doesn't always necessarily
present the answers but it understands
it sometimes the answers are so murky
that lets just present the problem and
show you how to guys who don't really
have a way out have to deal with it and
I found it in thrala knife out this was
one of the best acted and best written
films I've seen all year the director is
Carlos Lopez Estrada and I thought he
was also phenomenal the way he chooses
to focus on certain things more than
once he definitely develops a routine
for Colin's character the way he wakes
up the way he turns off his alarm the
way he goes jogging and we see the
progression of his character psychosis
after seeing a terrible event and how
each of those morning routine things he
always does every morning changes subtly
throughout the film and and I thought it
was really brilliant in regards to
editing and and pacing this film is
quite amazing actually and I was kind of
blown away with how much he was able
do with really just a couple characters
and some really beautiful locations I
mean visually the movie is stunning the
the places in Oakland that he films the
graffiti the the back alleyways the way
he uses lighting in the opening scene in
particular with these three guys sitting
in a car there's purple lights there's
blue lights and they're all amazed by
these guns this guy has and that that
leads me into something that I really
did not expect I did not expect this
movie to be as funny as it is it's
actually hilarious
despite some really serious subject
matter I found myself laughing
consistently especially with Myles
because he has a way with words there's
an early scene where he asks somebody
for a box filled with haircare products
and he goes to this salon which is
filled with women and he tries to sell
all of these haircare products to the
women and it's one of my favorite scenes
in the film
whenever Myles tries to sell anything
it's quite hilarious this movie was a
big surprise I am saddened that it's not
really being seen that much it was only
in Cleveland for a very brief time and I
saw it yesterday and today as I film
this it's actually gonna leave the
theater so if you guys have it in a
theater near you I would definitely
suggest seeing it because I don't know
if it's doing that well box office wise
and I don't know if it has much of a
push behind it
I know critics are digging it and I know
the people who have seen it like it but
I think this is one that I would love to
see more support something else that's
astonishing to me is the lead actors
here have actually written the film
daveed Diggs and Raphael Castle and I
apologize if I said your names
incorrectly not only are they portraying
the lead characters but they wrote this
film and so it's clearly very personal
to them and they've done an excellent
job at crafting two extremely realistic
and grounded characters that feel fresh
and that feel unique and like I said the
film explores some dark territory but
somehow miraculously does it in a
somewhat light-hearted way that being
said the film does have its dark moments
two scenes in particular that I am NOT
going to forget anytime soon one
argument between the two friends in
which the lead is trying to convince his
friend that you're really the real
problem here not me man you're the
reason I'm getting into so much trouble
and I thought it was absolutely riveting
I was
food to the screen for every word out of
their mouths it was incredible and a
final kind of confrontation I won't get
into it and it was just amazing stuff
there's a few small issues I have with
the movie and most of it is just some
tone problems sometimes the humor
doesn't necessarily flow as well with
some of the more serious elements like I
said it's amazing how funny the movie
actually is but there were some scenes
where it was a little jarring like I was
still very affected by something was
very sad or depressing and then all of a
sudden we have this humor but at the
same time it kind of captures their
lives perfectly because these two guys
are in an environment that's making life
difficult on them but they also are
funny guys and they've been friends for
a long time and they have to hustle a
little bit and do things that they're
not a hundred percent excited about
doing and so it's funny but the tone
really just every so once in a while it
was just wasn't perfect and that's
really it blind spotting is one of my
favorite movies I've seen so far this
year like I said it was in a theater
near you please do see it I'm gonna give
it an a guys thank you so much as always
for watching look forward to more
reviews very soon and if you like this
you can click right here and get stuck
mine eyes
[Music]